yeah it's frustrating i mean we've dealt
with that with marvel and uh you know it
feels good to be a part of something
that is making social progress but it's
uh it's with this ribbon of uh
bittersweet frustration that at the same
time there are still places that have
not caught up the stars of disney's
pixar lightyear hit the red carpet to
promote the upcoming film and while the
day was filled with joy from infinity
and beyond the cast and crew weighed in
on the recent news that the movie has
been banned in a few countries due to a
same-sex kiss
you know what i feel like it's terrible
but at the same time i feel like
we're going to push through that you
know i have a lot of faith and i think
storytelling and filmmaking it always
sometimes it's not i want to say before
it's time but it's on the brink of
things like this and so i just feel like
you know what it is what it is i'm glad
it's out there and where it is and i
know in the future it'll be in those
places as well i don't think that
there's anything in this film that is is
inappropriate for anybody i think this
is film that talks about focusing on the
future and appreciating what you have
and not living in regret and
um and loving and just everybody in the
film should and in our lives should love
right so i'm sorry they don't get to see
that to infinity are you trying to get
me to pull your finger don't fall for it
no not like that
sorry it's the thing your grandma and i
used to do yeah
hey thanks for watching et canada if you
want more queer entertainment news and
exclusive interviews be sure to
subscribe and check out